[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport le magazine est consacrée comme
vous le savez à l'actualité sportive
dans le département c'est parti pour le
sommaire rugby mauvaise opération pour
le sky dans le championnat de division
honneur
les saint quentinois se sont inclinés
dans les toutes dernières secondes
contre vitry lors de la 3e journée
le résumé du match dans ce magazine tir
à l'arc le championnat de france par
équipes 3d était organisé ce week-end à
magny-les-hameaux
plus de 250 archers de v a visé des
cibles en trois dimensions reportage à
suivre
cyclisme une étape de coupe du monde sur
piste sera organisée les 19 20 et 21
octobre prochain au vélodrome national
de saint quentin en yvelines
la fédération française a dévoilé les
prises les pistards qui sont présents
sur ce rendez vous font l'actualité
sportive de la semaine c'est maintenant
sur tv 68
[Musique]
les amoureux du rugby nous attendait ce
match avec impatience la rencontre de
division honneur entre le sky rugby et
vitry a longtemps indécise a finalement
tourné à l'avantagé des joueurs du val
de marne le sky s'incline dans les
toutes dernières minutes 22 à 18 après
une belle prestation
le résumé du match des images de nicolas
landry un montage de romain haruspices
un combat de tous les instants des
actions de grande classe ce dimanche 7
octobre la rencontre entre les bleus et
verts du sky rugby vitry a tenu toutes
ses promesses
après une première période convaincante
ponctuée par deux essais les saint
quentinois mène logiquement à la
mi-temps à 15 à 3 on fait une première
mi temps
bonn en à leur encontre on doit on doit
plutôt attendre la mi temps se dire que
il faut courber le dos un petit peu et
au contraire c'est nous qui prenons
germain
au retour des vestiaires vitré montre un
autre visage et revient à 15 partout sur
cet essai le match se durcit sur cette
action à la dernière seconde les
visiteurs arrache la victoire au bout du
suspense
score final 22 18 sentiment c'est que on
a bien maîtrisé match on a pris les
devants et et on a attendu que ça
finisse en fait on va subit un peu la
fin et résultat bat caen attend on
attend la bo défend de la niña monde et
ça finit chez doigt après cette défaite
le sky rugby abandonne sa place de
leader de division honneur et pointe à
la deuxième place avec la aujourd'hui
mentalement ça fait très mal parce que
c'est notre premier match à domicile on
se disait que ou des clauses allait être
imprenable cette saison quoi et puis en
plus avec deux victoires recteur pour
commencer on s'était mis dans de bonnes
conditions pour accueillir une équipe
comme vitry malheureusement ce match
mais un petit coup derrière la tête
prochain match pour les joueurs du sky
rugby ce dimanche 14 octobre sur le
terrain de vincennes pour le choc de
cette poule de division honneur
entre le deuxième et le troisième du
championnat on continue par du rugby
direction la fédérale 2 plaisir a
concédé sa quatrième défaite de la
saison en quatre matches disputés sur le
terrain de beauvais les plaisirs oies se
sont largement inclinés 40 6 à 7 dans
une rencontre la défense a sombré au
classement le psg occupe la dernière
place du championnat avec déjà trois
points de retard sur le premier non
relégable le havre toujours en rugby
dans le championnat honneur verset
continue sa bonne lancée lors de cette
troisième journée les versets ils se
sont facilement imposés contre
goussainville gonesse sur le score de 55
à 10 au classement versailles dominé
débat avec 14 points en trois matches
équipes comptent un petit point d'avancé
sur son dauphin le rc paris 15
on joue également sur les terrains de
football dans le championnat de r3 trap
a été freinée par sur rennes ce week-end
à domicile les trappistes qui restait
sur trois victoires en trois matches ont
concédé le match nul 3 buts partout
mais reste tout de même sur le fauteuil
de leader après quatre journées trappe
comptent un point d'avancé sur le second
à boulogne billancourt ans on passe
maintenant au championnat de division 1
de district 4e journée plaisir a concédé
le match nul 0 à 0 sur son terrain
contre le chesnay
tout comme hardricourt contre morrow pas
score nul et vierge lui au cours
s'impose 1 à 0 à l'extérieur contre de
carrière grésillons le fc mantois
arrachent le match nul 2 partout contre
oui enfin à gargenville l'emportent 5 1
contre montesson le chesnay reste leader
de la division baseball à présent très
mauvaise opération pour les cougars de
monti le bretonneux en finale du
championnat de france désigné mon teint
se sont inclinés deux fois sur les deux
premiers matchs de leur série
le score à 4-1 dans le premier match et
4 à 3 dans la seconde partie les matches
retour sont programmés le week-end
prochain monti le bretonneux devra
impérativement remporter ses trois
matches pour espérer devenir champion de
france
mais ça va être très dur hein on ouvre
maintenant une page handball coup de
projecteur sur deux des équipes phares
du département à ma droite on retrouve
les seniors 2 plaisir le pivot arnaud
chastre et guillaume gauthier ailier
droit de l'autre côté à ma gauche on
retrouve deux maillons forts de l'équipe
de handball féminin de monts
le bretonneux denys choulet l'entraîneur
et pauline bigot la pivot bonsoir nous
allons tout d'abord commencer par les
plaisirs wa nous allons revenir sur ce
match de ce week-end ce match de
nationale 3 vous êtes inclinés 25 à 24 à
domicile contre massy est ce que c'est
vraiment une déception d'avoir perdu
cette rencontre d'un petit but
j'imagine que oui alors c'est pire
qu'une déception pour nous aujourd'hui
on avait rivière quand ce n'est en tout
cas on avait toutes les clefs du match
pour le gagner tout simplement
c'est une faillite collective et
individuelle n'a rien d'autre à dire
guillaume qu'est-ce qui n'a pas
fonctionné sur cette rencontre on
commence bien très bien même
défensivement puis après on se pourquoi
je sais pas faudra qu'on s'y explique je
pense entre nous et on verra mais il
faut vite rebondir en tout cas ça c'est
sûr l'équipe de ma cité vraiment plus
forte que vous non pour moi non en plus
ils perdent leur gardien sur un carton
rouge c'est un joueur qui remplace le
gardien et on n'arrive pas à gagner le
match comme ça donc faut se remettre en
question il faut avancer aller de
l'avant et d'avoir plus de hargne pour
gagner ces matches à halle où vous êtes
d'accord avec votre coéquipier ben je
vous ai dit que c'était une faille et
ans était pas c'était le bon mot je
pense pas de ne pas d'autres denis
chevalier vous qui avez un regard un
petit peu extérieur / / plaisir qu'est
ce que vous pensez de ces défaite d'un
but d'écart donc plaisir arrivants
niveau national depuis peu je pense que
yako mg dire une apprentissage aussi à
faire à ce niveau là or je dis pas que
ça rien à voir avec le niveau mais au
niveau national vous avez toujours un ou
deux joueurs dans une équipe qui est en
soi un ancien pro soit je vais dire une
ancien joueur de haut niveau qui
arrivent à faire la différence et le
plaisir j'ai vu jouer quelques quelques
matchs l'année dernière ils ont une très
très belle équipe très collective et va
falloir qu'ils s'adaptent aussi j'allais
dire à la fois l'arbitrage où on laisse
beaucoup plus jouer ou ou là où les
arbitres temps en temps la règle de
l'avantagé qu'il y avait peut-être pas
au niveau régional en tout cas au niveau
féminin c'est souvent le cas et puis
aussi j'allais dire vraiment avoir la
vision du jeu où ça va beaucoup plus
vite
le plaça sa part très vite mais je
savais que j'allais dire les cadres qui
aa plaisir et les joueurs aussi surtout
c'est une équipe qui est merveilleuse et
donc ça fait ça sera dieu de faire faire
partie de des équipes de championnat de
france depuis au moins une dizaine
d'années et là il arrive tout juste par
manque de chance parce que les années
précédentes soit ruelle soit soit notre
équipe leur avait barré la route
mais c'est une équipe qui devrait
évoluer en chemin de france depuis bien
longtemps
là ce que je vois c'est qu'ils y sont
ils vont y rester
maintenant comme le vous avez un regard
optimiste abba complètement aller voir
jouer c'est très beau à voir et puis ça
va être important
arnaud online dernière vous avez failli
monter en nationale 2 pour un but aussi
également vous avez raté du coup cette
montée cette année où votre entame de
championnat n'est pas forcément aussi
bonne que koné dernière un peu plus
délicate vous êtes 7e actuellement avec
un bilan de une victoire et deux
défaites
est ce que vous attendiez un début de
saison comme celui là un peu plus
timorés c'est gentil de remuer le
couteau dans la terre
vous avez fois les dilutions bien c'est
toujours compliqué on a fait une prépa
qui a été un peu difficile où tout le
monde n'est pas arrivé en même temps
beaucoup de joueurs sont arrivés un peu
sur le tard dont faut s'adapter après je
crois qu'en termes de bilan
c'est le même que l'année dernière sur
trois matches il me semble à vérifier ou
alors en étant versé je me suis un
public mais vu la coupe de france ouais
mais ça c'est la fin des anecdotes hic
mais on ne devrait pas être à ce bilan
là encore une fois c'est prendre le bon
wagon en ce début de saison on a encore
l'impression qu'on est dans une poule
étrange où tout le monde bat tout le
monde ya que strasbourg à kehl à un
petit peu au dessus du lot ou mais tous
les résultats semblent confirmer encore
cette couleur un peu bizarre comme
l'année dernière et il faut pas qu'on
loupe le coche quoi il faut suivre les
bonnes équipes et typiquement ce
week-end va c'est un mauvais résultat
pour nous ça mauvais aux résultats pour
la continuité de la saison tout
simplement
alors nous allons maintenant parler à
des féminines de montigny-le-bretonneux
vous avez vous aussi perdu ce week-end
contre tall carantec 36 à 25 à
l'extérieur en championnat de nationale
2 comment expliquez vous cette défaite
police
bah on a bien commencé le match pendant
les vingt premières minutes mené on
arrivait à 7 7 6 me semble que c'est ça
et ensuite on peut perdre notre demi
centre qui font que notre capitaine et
qui a beaucoup d'expérience et on a
appris un peu l'homme a essayé de
relever la tête mais malheureusement
avec les déplacements tout ça c'était
peut-être pas nous pour nous l'équipe
est elle déjà en place sont à bout
pauline comment l'équipe est elle déjà
en place nous ravit enfin il ya six mois
encore du temps pour voir que les loyers
mayonnaise prenne comme on dit il ya
beaucoup de nouvelles donc oui forcément
faut qu'on continue à travailler toutes
ensembles vocaux continue à travailler
collectivement
quels sont les objectifs de la saison
disons que l'objectif numéro 1 se
maintient je pense qu'à ce niveau là on
va pouvoir y arriver
angers des joueuses de qualité mais
surtout comme le dit pauline on a
recruté beaucoup de joueuses de très
jeunes joueuses surtout qui arrive avec
pas beaucoup d'expérience au niveau je
parle france aucune n'a joué en
championnat elles étaient tous en région
ou un département les dernières on les a
on les a recrutés par ce que l on a des
qualités physiques ça va très vite c'est
pour très vite donc d'autres projets de
genou se répartir sur le sol de la
contre attaque est par contre elles ont
encore beaucoup à apprendre au niveau du
jeu placé technique et du terrain et on
a fait une petite
une petite parenthèse là dessus parce
qu'on va pouvoir travailler ça sur
l'année nous notre objectif c'est du
moyen terme et avec des joueuses de
qualité comme ça qu'ils ont envie de
progresser je pense qu'on n'y arrivera à
quoi merci à vous quatre d'être passé
sur ce plateau nous vous souhaitons bon
courage pour la suite de la saison et
surtout plein de victoires
merci à vous quatre on ouvre une page
tir à l'arc à présent le championnat de
france 3d par équipes de clubs étaient
organisées ce week-end à magny les
hameaux 250 archet sont venus de toute
la france pour tenter de viser à des
cibles fixes repos lisant à des animaux
des images de la robin des bois de la
rédaction à mélanie poké malgré les
apparences c'est archi ne sont pas sur
une partie de chasse mais sur le
compétition de tir à l'arc
leur objectif remporter les championnats
de france de tir par équipe de club
un rendez-vous qui clôture la saison
donc les archers ont un parcours à
réaliser
ils tirent sur des animaux qui peut
peut-être aussi historique fantastique
ou réelle cette année le site du musée
de port royal des champs de magny les
hameaux a été retenue pour organiser la
compétition du 6 au 7 octobre
le parcours a été soigneusement préparée
pour l'événement il faut un terrain
boisé un terrain vallonné pour pouvoir
avoir des cibles montant descendante
avoir une des variations de 2,2 pas
tirer d'eux
deux situations de tirs au total 250
archers venus des quatre coins de la
france sont venus sur ce rendez-vous
chaque équipe était composée de trois
sportifs là c'est le plus haut niveau
parce que la sélection se fait par
rapport au classement national de ce que
les archers ont fait réaliser tout le
long de l'année
donc c'est vraiment les 40 premières
équipes du classement qui sont là où les
25 équipes chez les féminines qui sont
là donc on est ici généralement on
retrouve des archers qui sont dans le
meilleur niveau en individuel dans ses
équipements la compétition a finalement
été remporté par les archers du sia
c'est comme le veut le règlement ce sera
cette équipe vainqueur d'organiser la
prochaine édition de ces championnats de
france 3 d un mot de golf à présent la
ryder cup c'est terminé depuis le
dimanche 30 septembre après une
somptueuse victoire de l'europe contre
les états unis après la fête l'heure est
au démontage au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines 300 personnes
sont présentes sur le site pour enlever
au plus vite les structures le dernier
camion devrait repartir à la mi novembre
les fans de golf peuvent tous domaines
mais tout de même être rassuré tout ne
sera pas à démonter ou enlever le golf
national devrait garder des stickers de
la compétition sur certains de ses murs
le vestiaire de la team europe sera lui
aussi conservé dans son intégralité
ces kiss me sur piste la fédération
française a dévoilé ce jeudi à l'épi
stars qui participeront à la coupe du
monde au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les 19 20 et
21 octobre prochains
les spectateurs pourront voir sur la
piste les multiples champions du monde
françois pervis et grégory baugé les
nouvelles pépites florian m et sébastien
vigion encore bryan coquard et sandie
clair plus de 3000 à spectateurs sont
attendus chaque jour pendant la
compétition
la star de cette étape de coupe du monde
sera sans aucun doute mathilde de gros
la jeune star de 19 ans remporté à cet
été médaille d'or en keirin lors des
derniers championnats d'europe et la
sportive espère faire aussi bien à
domicile pendant cette étape de coupe du
monde
nous avons eu la chance de pouvoir la
rencontrer à regarder une étape de coupe
du monde sont organisées ici au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les 19 20 et
21 octobre prochains à mes côtés et
mathilde de gros mathilde comment
appréhendez-vous cette compétition m'a
déjà su c'est vraiment très très ravi
que cette compétition ici
chez nous le rende
saint-quentin-en-yvelines c'est énorme
pour moi ça va être la première fois que
je vis une grosse compétition ici à
domicile donc voilà va falloir essayer
de ne pas trop se mettre la pression ça
va être une chose nouvelle pour moi on
va voir comment je réagis j'espère que
ça se passera bien et j'espère que je
donne enfin que tout cas j'aurai une
belle médaille pour mes amis ma famille
volonté environ 3000 personnes ici vous
le double nationaux 58 sur chaque jour
de compétition est ce que c'est quelque
chose qui va vous booster ou justement
vous stresser un petit peu honnêtement
je pense pas trop à ça c'est vrai que
voilà je vais arriver sur ce point sur
cette compétition en disant que c'est
une coupe du monde comme les autres que
voilà qu'il faut pas se mettre la
pression
je vais rester dans ma bulle et je pense
que quand le public va vraiment boosté à
ce moment là sur les derniers mètres je
pense que ça va être que du bonus pour
moi
et comment on fait pour compenser
justement ce petit manque d'expérience
je rappelle que vous n'avez que 19 ans
face à des filles qui sont parfois plus
âgés et qui en dix ans de plus que vous
mais juste croire en soi en ses
capacités voilà faire confiance à son
entraîneur à son entourage rester dans
son truc voilages et j'ai prouvé que je
suis là chaque compétition enfin
j'essaye d'être là et je vais tout
donner et puis on verra bien le résultat
final quels sont vos objectifs justement
sur cette compétition vous comptez
remporté des médailles
j'espère être sur le podium sur chaque
épreuve après vraiment tout donner parce
que c'est vrai que ça va être très très
compliqué mais bon moi j'aime bien les
défis
je vais tout donner repousser mes
limites et aller chercher sa médaille
c'est quoi une étape de coupe du monde
c'est une compétition intermédiaires ou
une compétition on se prépare
sérieusement pendant des mois et des
mois pour atteindre l'objectif c'est une
compétition intermédiaire en vue des
championnats du monde on ne peut pas
être à 100% de nos capacités à cette
manche de coupe du monde et celle
d'après est encore celle d'après c'est
pas possible
mais on arrive forcément en forme sur
cette compétition là donc voilà les
compétitions les coupes du monde ça nous
permet de travailler donc
moi je vais tout faire pour aller le
plus loin possible dans le tournoi de
vitesse et de keirin pour pouvoir
engranger un maximum d'expérience
justement physiquement vous sentez
comment pour l'instant je me sens bien
après on verra
à la compétition on fera avec la forme
du moment vous serez aligné en vitesse
individuelle vitesse par équipes et
kirin 3,3 compétition est-ce que c'est
pas trop non non non c'est le le quota
normal on va dire enfin toutes les
autres crimes thèse comme voilà
christina auquel elle a été championne
du monde fin sur les faits les trois
jeux olympiques elle a fait les trois
toutes les autres sprinteurs sont les 3
il y en a même qui font le 500 m en plus
donc enfin voila moi c'est mémé vraiment
mes disciplines vitesse individuelle et
le kirin est là cette année enfin voir
on a de la chance il ya 110 clair aussi
qui est très forte qui est la démarche
de notre vitesse par équipes et on fait
une superbe but et spar acquis toutes
les deux merci beaucoup matip de gros à
cette étape de coupe du monde ce sera à
les 19 20 et 21 octobre prochain au
vélodrome nationale 2 à saint quentin en
yvelines
[Musique]
lebron james michael jordan ou encore
kobe à bryant ceux des noms qui vous
font peut-être rêvé pour ceux qui
voudraient un jour devenir des vrais
stars de la nba
vous pouvez commencer à tréteaux à
mélanie il y à des écoles de basket dans
les yvelines où vous avez rejoint en
plateau pour nous expliquer tout cela eh
oui mickaël moi je vous propose qu'on
parte s'intéresser à une école précise
celle du plaisir basket club alan le
mini basket est une labellisation
régional qu'ils ont tenue en 2016 pour
cette école trois catégories les moins
de 7 ans les moins de 9 et les moins de
11 ans un nom du responsable de l'école
en u7 nous on se base qu'elles sont sur
l'école de basket sur du ludique le jeu
apprentissage par le jeu
et ensuite le comité départemental des
yvelines met en place trois
rassemblements dans l'année pour que les
u7
voià sur un autre terrain font des
ateliers rencontres aussi d'autres
recettes des autres clubs puis face des
petites compétitions mais la priorité en
u17 c'est vraiment le ludique
l'apprentissage moteur du ludique certes
mais tout en apprenant quand même les
bases techniques à mélanie bah oui le
plus important même c'est d'apprendre à
manipuler le ballon de faire de la
motricité apprendre à dribbler à se
déplacer tout en gris blanc ce qui n'est
pas toujours facile il faut surtout
apprendre à tirer et j'ai rencontré des
joueurs de l'école sir et marquer
et faire des matches donne donc du côté
mon papa ses preuves une religion
pourquoi
continuer sa marqué les paniers mais
quel est ce que vous connaissez george
eddy oui bien sûr c'est un ancien joueur
je crois et surtout commentateurs
sportifs sur canal + depuis plus de
trente ans depuis plus de 30 ans et
surtout il était à plaisir ce samedi
puisqu'il est le parrain de l'école de
basket on est plus jeune
j'essaie de donner deux petites astuces
techniques qui peuvent éventuellement
les aider pour la suite
pour les peaux les plus âgés peut-être
des exercices du shoot ma spécialité
sous le choc
j'étais basketteur pro pendant 15 ans et
il est connu pour mon adresse à trois
points
alors l'école et bien sûr déjà victime
de son succès les équipes ont dû mettre
en place des listes d'attentes mais de
nombreux club yvelinois propose aussi
une école alors sont patientes sont
faits ou prospects un petit peu merci
mélanie pour toutes ces précisions on
vous retrouvera le mois prochain a pour
votre chronique junior qui est
maintenant une tradition dans ce set 8
sport on passe maintenant à notre agenda
à notre page agenda
[Musique]
on commence cet agenda par une course la
quatrième édition de la run and bike de
plaisir sera organisée ce samedi dans le
parc du château et le bois de la crâne
pour nous parler de ce rendez-vous nous
recevons sur ce plateau l'adjoint
délégué aux sports à la ville de plaisir
dominique modeste bonsoir et romain von
der vigueur un participant qui
participera à sa quatrième édition
run and bike alors qu'est ce que vous
attendez de cette quatrième édition
eh bien nous attendons et du public nous
attendons des sportifs nous attendons
des des temps et surtout du beau temps
pour que les gens puissent apprécier la
course mais pas que la course le cadre
aussi dans lequel elle va se dérouler
alors un sportif vous en avez un juste à
côté de vous pourquoi vous participer
pour la quatrième fois cette compétition
alors moi je participer à la quatrième
édition parce que le premier anneau et
en partenariat que le gall et ketty club
le club auquel je fais de l'athlétisme
et je fais depuis quatre années parce
que ça rentre dans un dans un comment
dire dans un cursus d'entraînement tout
simplement et je fais ça avec mon frère
avec le plaisir de m'entraîner et le
plaisir de courir dans les bobos parc du
château de déplaisir donc il ya
plusieurs courses un don un 15 km et 1 8
km quels seront les difficultés sur son
rendez vous alors les difficultés sur ce
rendez vous c'est un parcours qui est
quand même assez roulant on va très vite
puisque les premiers arrivent en 50
minutes 1 il faut en 51e d'un jaune et
il me semble bien les l'année dernière
ils ont
ils ont des lièvres des véritables
lièvre puisque cette course on va
prenons par exemple la course de 15 km
c'est une course donc d'adultes à partir
de 10 de 18 ans et vous avez des
amateurs mais vous avez aussi je vais
dire des semi pros puisque ce sont des
gens qui sont quand même inscrit dans
des fédérations notamment la fédération
française de triathlon
ils vont vraiment très très vite c'est
une course piégeuse
ou pas ils étaient partis qui sont assez
piégeuse dont par les goûts vos plats
peut-être dans certaines parties il ya
un peu de faux plat mais je pense qu aux
rebelles pourrait peut-être pas s'ils
sont assez compliquées d'une dont une au
départ qui est un faux plat ce qui a
très longtemps et une grande côte qui
fait vraiment très mal aux jambes à la
suite de ça la petit qui monte qui monte
un petit peu vite et repartir c'est un
petit peu compliqué mais le parcours en
soi et et roulant mais avec des
difficultés qui sont bien placés qui
permet de faire plaisir se faire mal
c'est une course qui est vraiment
accessible à tous où il faut quand même
un petit peu de préparation
alors il faut de la préparation quand
même parce que c'est une course qui est
un peu technique dans la mesure vous
avez vous alternez entre le vélo et la
course à pied
donc il faut quand même se passer le
relais au bon moment il faut pas oublier
qu'on part à deux et qu'on revient à 2
donc il n'est pas question de se passer
par exemple
de partir devant laisser le vélo et
partir à pied pour que l'autre viennent
il faut vraiment le faire de manière
coordonnée
oui justement c'est très stratégique 1
comme course comment on fait pour
réussir la meilleure formule
tout dépend des forces de chacun on va
dire mais en moyenne du moins quand
participants il faut ni salé les forces
et les faiblesses de son coéquipier à
vendre avant dernière ça lequel est en
forme le cas les temps mais forment donc
nous on part sur un principe de 30
secondes 30 secondes 30 secondes
d'effort 36 secondes de vélo donc ce qui
permet d'économiser et de sur les 15 km
à faire made être d'arriver dans ces
conditions un petit peu d'épuisantes à
la fin et on arrive un petit va gérer
tout ça comme comme il se doit romain à
la meilleure stratégie qui seront trente
secondes après je pense que c'est chacun
c'est à chacun de vos achats qui à
chaque équipe de voir tous les pins les
qualités individuelles de chacun
l'esprit d'équipé c'est forcément la
base vraiment de cette course
oui bien sûr alors c'est vraiment la
base de cette course puisque on a
plusieurs courses quand même si on parle
de d2 grande course du matin c'est à
dire celle de 15 et celle de 8
ça peut être faits soient deux hommes
soient deux femmes soient mixtes donc il
faut vraiment que qui est une bonne
coordination et que les personnes
septembre
la question est ce qu'on peut venir
encourager les participants tout à fait
oui oui c'est recommandé
ça vous avez encore plus quand vous avez
des supporters au bord de la route
départ c'est toujours bien après avoir
de la route on est comme en forêt n'ont
qu'à prendre en contre en compte du
monde est toujours quelqu'un qui est un
footing qu'on connaît qui nous
encouragent et puis bon après l'arrivée
se fait dans le parc du château de
plaisir donc automatiquement
on a toujours quelqu'un qu'on connaît se
fera rêver qui nous encourage et pure ça
fait toujours plaisir et votre objectif
sur cette course ça sera quoi enfin les
10 premiers dans les dix premiers
victoire peut-être je pense pas que je
puisse qu'elle aille jusqu'à victoire
mais en moyenne on est dans les dix
premiers confrères donc pourquoi pas
être dans les dix premiers on suivra
avec attention tout cas merci à tous les
deux dépassé sur ce plateau je rappelle
que le run and bike 2 plaisir est
organisée ce samedi entre le parc du
château et le bois de la crâne on
continue par de la course à pied la 9e
édition du trail des sept hameaux au
départ de la commune de magny les
hameaux sera organisée ce dimanche 14
octobre le premier départ pour le traite
de
32 km sera donné à 9 heures la seconde
vague pour le départ des 18 km en pleine
nature sera donné à 9h30
enfin une randonnée sera lancée à 9h45
on attend plus de 400 concurrents sur
l'épreuve
et puis en basket trappe se rendra sur
le terrain de barjouville pour le compte
de la 4e journée du championnat de
nationale 3 les trappistes doivent
absolument l'emporter xiabo réussir une
victoire lors de ce déplacement pour
conserver leur place de leader les
yvelinois ont un bilan de trois
victoires en trois matchs depuis le
début du championnat avec plus de 311
points marqués en seulement trois
rencontres
c'est la fin cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve à lundi
prochain pour un nouveau magazine à 10
il a passé une excellente semaine
sportive très belle soirée sur tv à 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]